تنضم الينا من اوديسا ناتاليا وهي
المتحدثه باسم قياده العمليات الجنوبيه في
الجيش الاوكراني اهلا
بك ما روايه او الادله التي تقدمها
اوكرانيا لتؤكد روايتها بان موسكو هي التي
تقف وراء تدمير هذا السد
اولا نحن
لا
نقصف منشات البنيه التحتيه الحيويه واذا
كنا نريد تدمير السد كنا قمنا بهذا منذ
تحرير الضفه اليمنى وما الذي تستفيده
روسيا من تدمير هذا السد
يدرس
الشيء الثاني ان مقاطع الفيديو
التي لدينا توضح ان الانفجار كان داخليا
وليس من الخارج
ماذا عن سؤالي بخصوص ما الذي
ستستفيد منه روسيا من تفجير هذا السد
لذلك اريد ان اقول ان الضرر الاكبر هو ما
تقوم به روسيا على نفسها لان الضفه اليسرى
اقل
ارتفاعا لذلك المياه قامت باغراق الضفه
اليسرى حيث القوات الروسيه وهناك اغراق
كبير ان الطرف الايمن ليس هناك فيضانات
كبيره ولكن المواطنين قاموا بالخروج من
منطقه مبكره
طيب روسيا تقول ان اوكرانيا هي التي قامت
بذلك لصرف الانظار عن ما تسميه بهجومها
المضاد
المتعثر كيف تردين على هذا الكلام
نحن نعلم جيدا من هو الارهابي الحقيقي
ونعلم من يقوم
بهذه المشاكل والظروف الصعبه ونعلم من
يخشى من الهجمات العكسيه الاوكرانيه
المسلحه ولهذا
قاموا بتفجير هذا السد ان الروس هم من
كانوا يسيطروا على المدخل
للسد ومن كان ممكن ان ينظم هذا التفجير
فقط هم لذلك هذا واضح حتى الان من الواضح
انهم يخدعوا ويتهموا اوكرانيا ولكن
التحقيقات سوف تقدم جميع الدلائل على
كذبهم تجمع القراءات على ان ما جرى لسد
نوفا كخوفكا سيكون منعطف في المعركه في
اوكرانيا كيف ستتعاطف او ستتعاطف معه
السلطات الاوكرانيه
اما الكارثه
التكنولوجيه لن يكون لها اثر كبير على ارض
المعركه المعركه هي على ارضها حيث
العمليات العسكريه غير مرتبطه
بافخاخ والمشاكل الذي يقوم بها العدو
شكرا جزيلا لك نتاليا المتحدثه باسم قياده
العمليات الجنوبيه في الجيش الاوكراني
حدثتينا من اوديسا
من
فلاديمير عضو الاداره الروسيه في مقاطعه
اهلا بك اوكرانيا تتهم روسيا بالمسؤوليه
عن ما جرى لتحقيق مكاسب
عسكريه ما تعليقك
انا افهم جيدا ان مشاهدين الجزيره ليسوا
بالحمقى ودعونا نسال من المستفيد
لقد حررنا الضفه اليسرى من
وقوه هم في الضفه اليمنى الضفه اليمنى
اعلى بكثير ولذلك لان المياه
بكميات كبيره
اغرقت الضفه اليسرى نعلم ان هذا ليس
بمصلحتنا لذلك بمصلحه من هذا التفجير هذا
بمصلحه العدو ونظام زيلينسكي وقواته ان
الفيضانات في الجانب الايسر اخطر بكثير
والالاف يهجرون الان ونقدم لهم الاماكن
السكانيه
ما الذي يستفيده النظام الاوكراني من
تفجير هذا السد
رد بسيط جدا هم الان في زبولوجيا حيث انا
قاموا بمحاولات للهجمات وخسروا بعض الالاف
ومئات المعدات
وليس لديهم ما يكفي من الجنود لذلك يريدون
ان يحولوا قواتهم من خرسون الى ولكنهم لا
يستطيعوا ان يقوموا بهذا بسهوله اما بعد
تفجير وتدمير السد في كخوفكا فهم
يحاولون ان يوجهوا قواتهم من موقع الدفاع
ويريدون تحويل الالاف من الجنود الى
زبولوجيا وهذا يحل مشاكل القدرات العسكريه
انوشكا وكخوفسكا مناطق يخرجون القوات
العسكريه منها الى مواقع اخرى وهم يهاجموا
الق درات الزراعيه
هذه النقطه اصبحت واضحه لكن هل من المعقول
ان روسيا التي تسيطر على هذه المنطقه التي
تستطيع حمايه هذا السد
السد في منطقه رماديه نحن على الطرف
الايسر وعلى الطرف الايمن القوات
الاوكرانيه عدا عن ذلك
السد كان قد دمر جزئيا بعد الضربات
بالانظمه الصاروخيه من راجمات الصواريخ
الامريكيه التي تصل لقوات زينينسكي واجزاء
من هذه الصواريخ الامريكيه موجوده وممكن
ان تشاهدوا الصور والفيديوهات التي اصابت
سابقا لذلك بمجرد ما حاولت قوات الصيانه
ان تصلح الاعطال كان كانوا يتعرضوا
للقصف لتقييد قدراتهم على صيانه المنشاه
اما دليل اخر على هذا ان
محطه توليد الكهرباء في ذابولوجيا التي
تحت نظام زينينسكي قاموا
بزياده ضخم الماء لزياده اغراق المناطق
الروسيه واذا كان المياه قد اغرت اغرقت
مناطقهم لما قاموا بهذا فهم يضخون الماء
بكميات كبيره حتى يغرقون بها شكرا جزيلا
لك عضو الاداره الروسيه في مقاطعه
زاكولوجيا حدثنا من ذا فورجيا